hello everyone sorry about no videos for
the past few days I decided that you
guys needed some time to check out all
the videos from the World Cup and I
really felt tired so so I took the
weekend for myself now getting back to
creating content of course I decided to
check up on some of your suggestions and
I was gonna do the conclusion to the
capablanca saga prior to checking up on
your suggestions but I can't find my
book on Capablanca now my girlfriend was
moving things around and and it's just
nowhere to be found I ordered another
one since I I don't see where it could
be it's like it you know fell into the
ground and it should be here in some
five days five days maybe a week and
then we're going to do the conclusion I
could do the conclusion without you know
consulting the book but there are always
things that would that will slip there's
something we want to say some very
interesting things that you'd never even
remember so I decided to wait for it
we've been covering the capablanca saga
for almost over a year now and it would
just be shamed it ended poorly in my
opinion so there being said it's one of
the games subscribers suggested to me on
Twitter it's stockfish versus Ellie
Stine it's the TCE see the top chess
engine competition super final season 16
and they are playing a 100 game match
they each have a 120 minutes so two
hours for the entire game plus 10
seconds increment per move and it's a
really really exciting game a very
attacking game and I'm sure you're going
to enjoy it as it's well stockfish your
well big bad stock fish versus a neural
network engine which is always something
interesting so we've seen in games
balilla hs0 now we're gonna check out a
game by Ellie Stein and if you would
like to learn something more about the
at least I know why she was created how
she was created and a bit more the first
link in the description below will will
take you to a very nice article where
you can read up and more about her now
getting getting to the game let's let's
just check it out so starfish with the
white pieces opens with E 4 we have C 5
the Sicilian defense by Ellie Stein
f 3 with East 6 and D for opening up the
position seek actress Knight captures
and now Knight to c6 we have the tamaño
variation on the board Knight to c3 by
stockfish Queen to c7 and an out Bishop
to e3 all standard stuff with a6 taking
away the B 5 squared from White's
Knights also the bishop and a3 we have
Knight to f6 and now comes f4 so this
has all been played before fairly often
these six and Queen to f3 preparing the
Castle queenside we have Bishop to e7
early prepares the Castle kingside and
now both players Castle with castles
castles and now Knight captures on c6
there is only one game where this was
played B captures and now g4 as we have
castles on opposite sides of the board
White will of course played g4 h4 h5
pushed upon all the way whereas Black
has the same open B file and some
attacking chances on the Queen side so
there is one game in the database were
look to be it was played right away but
here Ali first moves the knight Knight
to d7 this Knight cannot maybe come to
b6 to a4 at some point maybe to c5 maybe
maybe supported the the push of the
opponent c5 and also g5 will not come
with tempo when white pushes it so it is
a new move in the position and it is as
of move 12th that we have a completely
new game so stockfish continues
attacking on the King side with h4 and
now rook the d8 you always want to push
d5 when playing the Sicilian so why not
prepare it with h5 stockfish continues
the attack and did not look the BA this
rook will always be useful here on this
very nice open semi B file
Bishop to e2 and developing the bishop
connecting rooks and now finally d5
stockfish ignores this and continues the
attack on the King side with h6
now trying to create some weaknesses of
course black is not interested in in
capturing or allowing white to capture
so g6 just you know hoping for for g5
and the D attack is over but we have
rook H to f1 the rook is no longer
needed on the H file now we want to play
a 5 at some point hopefully open up the
F file and then the nice
rook queen battery will wreak havoc
along the F file and now Queen to a5
already
some threats here there are some very
nasty ideas here for example if you play
something like Bishop character Sunday 3
followed by Queen captors on c3 or if
white Hastings the attack maybe would
have 5 you can even go root cap for some
b2 and then you have problems here the
you will develop the bush of the rook
the arrow comes to b8 could be very
dangerous so here stock which just
brings the knight back nice the b1 as
the strongest move is often a move with
the knight back and and now Queen back
to c7 just retreating with the Queen
it's it's hard to do something more for
example you could try c5 but it does
seem a bit slow and if you try something
like Knight the c5 the problem with with
an idea like this is b4 now white can
actually play this and you just win a
piece since the a3 pawn is protected by
the knight so also one of the nice ideas
when the night comes back to be one so
Ali brings the Queen back Queen to c7
and now Knight back to c3 and okay Ali
says ok I'm playing with the black
pieces I'm I don't have a problem with a
draw Queen back to a5 and here stockfish
does not repeat and go for a draw but
stockfish says Bishop to d4 so no no
draw for a bad neural network friend and
we now have finally c5 now c5 is a bit
different as you don't waste time
playing it as it comes with an attack on
wise Bishop so c5 and now Bishop to g7
an odd square for the bishop but if it
works why not and now even d4 so Ali
gets a lot of expansion here because all
of the pone pushers come with an attack
on White's pieces so Knight back the b1
and here Queen to b6 now already
threatening Queen captures and b2 so you
have to prevent this and we have b3
seems a seems very weak as all of these
pawns are really coming at you creating
more weaknesses in front of your King
but you know it's it's tough if you can
make it work and now a5 preparing a 4 to
create even more weaknesses and now
Knight d2 first Bishop to e6 you want to
trade off your useless bishop on c8
connect rooks so seems like a logical
thing to do and now Knight the c-4 this
is
the defensive idea of soccer shot in
mind and now it's very very hard to
break through and it seems like you
could do something like Bishop captures
Bishop captures and a4 but it actually
favor stock fish for example stock fish
will ignore it and play f5 and now if
you persist in attacking a captors nb3
you will get F captors on e6 with the
thread of e captures on f7 mate or or
Queen captures on f7 mate doesn't really
matter
and even after Bishop g5 check you're
not gonna move the King in front of the
open B file soon to be open be file but
rather rook the detour just gonna block
it prevent any checks if B to check King
b1 and you don't have a good
continuation each captures on f7 mate is
still lurking so you'd have to play some
like f6 but still pawn captures Knight
opens up a discovery from the bishop and
the only move is Queenie 6 followed by
Bishop captures an e6 checkmate
so although captures and a4 seems like a
good attacking idea it's really not so
Queen back to c6 as the Queen was under
attack now you can't really do something
like e5 you can always trade Queens here
and now comes a 4 and look at how
beautiful Stockbridge is defensive setup
is there is no breaking through on the
Queen side if you capture them Bishop
characters on c4 it will just be an
awesome attacking piece and also an
awesome defensive piece so here
ally finds another interesting idea look
to be for the idea is just capture here
and then if Bishop recaptures you will
give up the exchange here for Queen
characters on a for you you're getting
the rook into the game and ended the
night as well and of course
stockfish is not interested in allowing
this one night the e5 now attacking the
Queen attacking f7 it would be too
dangerous to let the night live f5 is
coming so here ally decides to eliminate
the night we have Knight captures on e5
but now F characters on e5 opens up this
very dangerous F file we have Bishop to
g5 check by Ally
King Tubby one and now how do you
prevent mate well f6 and ok
bishop cap sorry that's wrong the shot
Bishop captures on f6 by stockfish and
now rook the f8 preventing any more
ideas along the F file and now
Elif sorry stocks which finds a
brilliant attacking idea first we have a
trade of Bishops
rook captures on a6 Queen captures on a6
and now feel free to pause the video and
try to find it this really awesome idea
stockfish had in this position
well I give you a couple of seconds for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations you are unnatural
attacker and the counter attacker but
also you know just it's a very nice move
and for those of you who just won't
enjoy it so it's actually Bishop
captures on g5 and yes you do give up
the Queen but for some insane tactics
rook captures of course route captors on
f3 and now White has a very simple idea
rook not there but rook to it sorry I
can't see the f1 Square from the
microphone F 1 followed by rook to f8
mate that's why it's idea and of course
you have to try and prevent it
Ali plays Queen to e7 this will be
followed by a rook to b8 this is the
defensive setup that Ellie chooses
whereas rook the b7 is another setup you
could go for but and we're just gonna
show it because it's really really just
crazy to see how stockfish is good at
brute force calculations so if rook to
b7 which stockfish gives as the the best
defensive resource rook d f1 going for
mate and then of course Queen to a8
preventing mate and offering a queen for
2 rooks of course if you play something
like group 2 f8 but now Bishop to f6 of
course Bishop to g7 will be played
followed by rogue here we have looked f7
and now Bishop to g7 so now the threat
is just you know capture here and rook
to f8 will be made so the idea is not
capturing the rook but actually
capturing on g7 with H captures on g7
and now Queen captures on e4 this is the
defensive idea that that stockfish
suggests now that rook to f8 check can
be met with King captures and g7 and you
have an escape route for your king
for example if Luke the f7 not allowing
this you might have ideas like rook the
d7 and then the other rook can mate on
FA then black gets some account or
attacking chances with d3 looked at e7
threatening rook to f8 made not be
captors and c2 and now kinked a to
avoiding all the checks but you still
persist with bringing a knight into the
game so knife comes in to him with
you have to play it with check out of
wise you're getting mated rook captures
an c1 and now Queen the g2 check King
the a3 and now Queen to c6 whereas you
get rook to d8 check now finally King
captors and G 700 g5 now again
preventing the black King from escaping
with the threat being rook to d1
followed by rook to d7 check and here
white white would be winning but you
would still have to grind for when you
have to be careful ideas like c4 are
coming then you have something like
Queen c7 followed by Queen e7 check
where you can pick up the g5 pawn so
really complicated position but it just
shows you how good stalker she is at
brute force calculations so here Ali
doesn't go for Luke the b7 the the line
that stockfish recommends but rather
goes for Queen to a7 followed by rook to
b8 and it's a different line but also a
very very enjoyable one so rook dita f1
threatening mate in one
and now rook to b8 preventing this with
Bishop f6 the idea is similar as in the
line we've shown and now g5 not allowing
white to poach g5 so maybe maybe you can
just get this in and get rid of the h6
pawn but Bishop to g7 of course and now
Queen to a 8 so preventing rope to f8
which would again be made if you don't
prevent it
you're gonna give check after black
captures the other rook will deliver
mate on f8 so here Queen to a 8 and now
how do you win this with white it's very
interesting and very educational if
you're a beginner but also if maybe you
just don't immediately see it the idea
is that well White has 7 points a black
has 6 points so if you eliminate all the
P all the big pieces from the board the
the King and pawn and game is pretty
much drawn because of White's double D
pawn but if for example White's King was
a bit more active for example somewhere
on d2 or and e3 maybe even c4 then rook
here would be winning for example you
could trade everything here captures
captures you're gonna go captures
captures captures captures and now well
whitey still up a pawn but the double
the Epona makes it very hard for you to
win and if you start going up the board
the reach of the c5 pawn black will be
in time of course to defend it
here instead of trading right away Black
has no moves black just have to wait
if you move anything Ruka fate is mate
if you leave the back rank so here you
of course in by now you already know
King to see one it's a very it's a
winning move because you just have to
start bringing your King and the ones
the king is a bit more active then you
trade everything off and the white king
is much closer to the pond than the
black king so here we have looked the
eight a waiting move by Ali and now King
to detail and now if you don't do
anything you just repeat moves then rook
to f8 will be winning for example we're
just gonna show it captures captures
captures captures captures and now King
D three wins the game King e7 King c4
and you don't have the the d6 square to
guard the c5 pawn white will just
capture it capture the d4 pawn and this
game over
so here Ali tried one last idea c4
creating some chances here but B
captures on c4 dr. doesn't mind he says
okay thank you for the past pawn we have
Queen to d8 now now there are two the
past two a double spawns here so it will
be much easier from black to defend if
white just goes for rook to f8 so c5
first now stop which says no I'm now now
I'm not going to improve the position of
my king I'm just gonna get to this point
as far up the board as I can and then
I'm gonna play rook to f8 Czech Queen to
e7 going after the pond but now c6 we
have Queen to b4 check and after going
to before check lh9 resigned the game or
as in when engines play or when both
engines have an evaluation I believe
below minus-10 the edibles agree that
black is completely lost then it's just
game over
so here it's game over because after you
move King see one there are no more
checks rope is covering a3 so no checks
there no checks here no checks here
everything is covered you have to play
something and you have to keep an eye on
the f8 square Serge is going to move the
Queen but now finally when the pony's
here now you're gonna play rook f8 check
captures captures only move Queen
captures captures captures and now d7
and there is no defense against c8 Queen
as the King is a 1 square short of
reaching the pawn so really really an
awesome game and like I said it's a it's
a 100 match game the current score is
twenty eight and a half
to 36 and a half in stockfish favor and
I know you're wondering why is the first
game I'm showing you a game where were
this neural network engine lost as Ellie
Stein also won some very nice games
against Rakesh
but the reason I'm I showed you this
game first is because it was suggested
to me I was never even aware at that
Ellie Stein existed as I'm not following
the TCC all that much I do check up on
Lila chess zero from time to time but
well I was just I was just very glad
that this was suggested to me and that
now I'm aware of this new neural
networking engine so the reason I really
enjoyed this game is because if you
watch a game stock fish vs. stocks or
stock fish vs. Houdini it will be just a
hundred and fifty moves game with with
with hardly something there are
exceptions of course but they are
they're very rare and the the way what I
enjoyed most here is is that the
difference when neural networks play is
just so refreshing for for example Ally
attacked with the black pieces a really
relentless try to create chances on the
queenside
allowed some chances for white on the
kingside but stop Fisher defended
brilliantly a very very beautiful
positional play by stockfish on the
queenside
completely stopped the attack and then
just went into a relentless attack so
sort of sort of a counter attack so here
stockfish play was sort of like like
watching Paul Karras play so that's why
I really enjoyed it and I do hope you
enjoyed it as well so naturally we're
not gonna leave it at this while I'm
waiting for my couple Blanca book to
arrive I'm gonna check up on some other
games bye bye Alex teen and we're gonna
also show a very nice game where maybe
Ali wins or maybe not we'll see how it
goes so that's the game I do hope you
enjoyed it always there will be some
useful links in the description below
where you can follow this competition
live you can check out all the other
games I will put a link to that as well
and if you want to read a bit more about
Alex town also the first link in the
description below so I would like to
thank Ray Johnson Gary branch Schmidt
Allen Wang Kathleen Northrup and tarish
cardiac for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and I will see you soon
continue to check up on your suggestions
and preparing for the couple
saga conclusion and also I received the
square of a chessboard you know the one
where you sort of play a play against
the ghost as the pieces on the board
move against themselves the the makers
of the board sent it to me if I wanted
to make a review video so it's currently
I'm reviewing the board and I'm Morgan
I'm gonna make a nice review video for
you so you guys can decide if you enjoy
it or not it's not sponsored so you know
everything I say and it will be my own
opinion so III do hope you will enjoy
that as well so thank you all I will see
you soon and have an excellent rest of
your day